we knew nothing about the industry we
were getting ready to go into it took us
three years to build the place out we
did all the work ourselves except for
the well and then we released our first
batches of spirits in late05 so the
first product we produced was from
apples and it was our vodka which is
indigenous that first batch was 128
bottles and then we started making age
spirits and we turned off the first
bourbon in 2006 and it turns out to have
been the first bourbon ever made in new
york
the thing that held us back in the
beginning since prohibition there had
been no distilleries in new york so
nobody had gone back and changed the
prohibition of era distillery law to
allow distilleries to have a tasting
room and offer samples and tourism sell
we started in 2005 to lobby in albany in
2007 the governor signed into law the
farm distillery act which allowed us to
have a shop
and do tastings and samplings and tours
at the distillery
last year we did over 30 000 visitors
this year we'll go well past that we've
reached out to a number of large
companies to see about their interests
but generally speaking no one had any
interest a typical reaction was bourbon
made in new york who's going to buy that
william grant and sons is one of the
most prestigious scotch houses
in the industry but we got a phone call
out of the blue we've never approached
them they bought the hudson brand from
us and we continue to make it and they
distribute it internationally
in 2011 we made 10 000 fruit gallons of
the year and in 2012 we made 60 000.
you'll probably do 70 to 75 000 in the
next year or so
we have taken almost nothing out of the
company i still drive a 1998 car because
every penny goes back into the business
to in order to meet that demand which
has been created by our success